yoga and Madam's prestige and here we
got another minecraft seed spotlight and
it's going to be a survival see like
that's a pipeline island just survival
of my nose sounds a bit stuffy hold on
five my nose stuffy nose is a bit stuffy
that's why I might settle them off do
any of you guys but let's hop right into
the seat so you spawn around here in
this uh Tyga and you instantly see a
awesome little cave place to a great
place to get breeding resources coal and
iron such and if we had a little bit
north we can see some above-ground lava
overflowing or looking all sexy and we
go into straight into this odd into this
extreme Hills biome and because art I'm
60 apologies I'm gloom of us to get the
video now this is a whoa okay no I want
to go up this is a amazing i love every
extreme Hills bottom i see but this one
is just crazy you can see here just like
but the is that water not pulling before
i guess not but this is it just crazy
like overhangs arches and like little
half ravines into the place i think this
is like an amazing place if i want to do
sorry if i want to do like a house in
this map I probably make it here on
another trip hills by let me show you
now you just see this is just crazy i
love i love extreme Hills so you guys
like 3000 sorry but uh if my seed spot
might a lot of my seat spotlights we're
gonna be go all my gosh and there's I've
done there's a dungeon in the side of
dick shemales like that you know this
evening autumn's of gunpowder and
saddles and cocoa beans you can't get
cocoa be done either way so
prevent you that's awesome well that's
awesome as a dungeon in the side of the
mountain that's beautiful as always on
chest there it was right now if we head
up north we'll see the second of the two
tigers the one first when he spotted the
second one has a little river running
through it and just has this stuff now I
wanted to show you one film over here
past the ice sheet and just get is do it
with right way so here we got a lot of
nice little i spawned but we got an ass
a crazy chasm right yeah right here that
is just look at that huge Falls that you
would easily die out i just passed about
at least 10 iron and like 20 coal and
there's like gold in here this is
amazing way to get to lower areas fast
if you want to go mine for diamonds or
try to find a lava or gold but for this
crap someone once i guess i'm gonna make
golden apples you use it but let's get
back to the service this is a huge chasm
awesome and one thing that i thought was
a little funny leave me a little longer
than my other ones but my other saliva
seen videos i see video spotlights i
really didn't explore the map that's
what i am this is a little failed
attempt at a village only the wells
phone and i promise you on my youtube
career that I did not build this I was
just flying around the map and I happen
to notice this and i find it hilarious
that is the only part to get spawn now
you see a however haps of that is pretty
will not have a third of the map is
ocean so and there the ida have it I
don't see any up above a bunch of the
frame was I don't see any mushroom
mushroom islands so that kind of sucks i
would suggest i would be like yell for a
survival island seat here let's go over
to you except for the fact that there
really are
many planes you see there's the forest
over here and another extreme Hills
they're just tigers and a few deserts
but like this one this extreme pills i
think is also awesome in its own right
because it's just it's more water or
limited because there's lakes and rivers
thank you to the whole thing and it's
just really awesome a key to make an
awesome perching house up here on this
precarious perch a car right you like
cop look at how beautiful it is but yeah
so I wouldn't uh I probably wouldn't
like it goes because I like playing so
much that is me well I'm gonna wrap up
this video I hope you guys all the drama
brah wrap it up with an amazing
background I'm not really looking that
I'm looking at camera okay stupid cross
her my face rude much fly alright guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
if you got this far I think you've
enjoyed it since if you haven't enjoyed
it and you probably just quit after like
five seconds so I appreciate anybody to
get this far if you got this far and you
enjoyed it leave it a like if you're new
subscribe if you enjoyed this kind of
these kind of videos since i'll be
posting this survival series so like
yeah there's good old minecraft fun and
prop some more some call duty that i
haven't posted i want to come up with a
new backpack but yeah so my guys my name
is Percy's plan as i said three million
times comment rate and you can do
subscribe peace out